a Larry on the dread the Beast the Dagon
rode across the sea his flames forged
the Iron Throne and brought the seven
kingdoms to heal
powerful
but not invincible this place was the
beginning of the end for my family so
the reasons was Dario's cost how old a
dragon is not a slave
they were terrifying extraordinary they
filled people with wonder and all and we
locked them in here they wasted away
they go small and we grew small as well
hey everybody so I got a lot of requests
to do a video about the origin and
history of dragons and because they're
so tied up in the history of the
Targaryen family I wanted to talk a
little bit about them too because the
origin of the Dragons is tied up in the
rise of the Valyrian freehold and some
themes of Ice and Fire there are a lot
of creation myths that they get into in
the books
then his Daenerys implies sort of the
downfall of the Dragons in the downfall
the Targaryen family and how those are
linked up but if you're finding me for
the first time I do Game of Thrones
every week so be sure to subscribe to
get everything
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video too so just to begin with the
creation myth of dragons there's a
fictional book with in Game of Thrones
called Septon births unnatural history
where he digs into some of the larger
beliefs about dragons so it reads the
Valerians themselves claimed the dragons
sprang forth as the children of the
fourteen flames while in Qarth the tales
states that there was once a second moon
in the sky one day this moon was scalded
by the Sun and cracked like an egg and a
million dragons poured forth in a shy
the tales are many in confused but
certain texts all impossibly ancient
claimed that the Dragons first came from
the shadow this place over here these
are shy histories say that people so
ancient they have no name first tamed
dragons in the shadow and brought them
to Valyria teaching the Valyrians their
arts before departing from the annals
yet if men in the shadow had tamed
dragons first why did they not conquer
as the Valyrian stood it seems a likely
er the Valerians tale is the truest but
there were dragons in Westeros once long
before the Targaryens came as our own
legends and histories tell us if dragons
did first spring from the 14 flames they
must have been spread across much of the
known world before they were tamed and
in fact there is evidence for this as
dragon bones have been found as far
north as if and even in the jungles of
the southern continent but the Valerians
harnessed and subjugated them as no one
else could so that sort of details the
myths behind the origin of dragons that
doesn't answer exactly how we got to the
point where people were riding dragons
that gets into a little bit of blood
magic in selective breeding over
centuries looking at the general
timeline of events in Game of Thrones
the rise of the Valyrian freehold Cohen
sided with the end of the first long
night so right as bran the Builder was
building the wall the Valyrians were
taming their dragons and conquering all
the lands in the east the TV show hasn't
officially confirmed the truest origin
of dragons but it has sort of backed up
the idea of dragons in the shadow of a
shy so a shy is where Melisandre comes
from she's a shadow bind her that's
where she learned how to make shadow
babies that's where she became a
follower of the red God when Illyrio
gives Daenerys the gift of dragon eggs
in the first episode he actually got
those from ash I we've never actually
been there on the TV show and maybe one
of the spin-offs will touch on it at
some point but the belief is is that
this coastline is just pockmarked with
ancient dragon caves so there are a lot
of petrified dragon eggs left there and
as far as we know we haven't seen any
dragons other than Daenerys but the idea
is is that the gift that he gives her of
dragon eggs are petrified dragon eggs
and it's through blood magic in mirror
master that they come back to life and
hatch so there are many different types
of magic on the TV show but as they've
sorted to sew things together the origin
of the White Walkers the children of the
forest the old gods it sounds like a lot
of that magic flows from the same source
so while the show hasn't officially
canonized any real consciousness behind
the old gods like you know their power
through their actions but you never hear
them speak directly there's no astral
projection saying I am the God of
everything this is the reason I do
things and I don't think that it's ever
gonna happen that way but cycle of Ice
and Fire myths about Azure 'hi go back
to the beginning of time so it's just
the idea that the Valerians
are put forth is this great people that
brought dragons to the world but these
other people from who Melisandre comes
learned about it a long time before that
you heard a voice call out from the
flames do you remember should I tell you
the name of the
so I think it's important to remember
that other red priests probably came to
Valyria sensing that they would be
important eventually taught them some of
their magic then they took that refined
it and you get to where dragons are
today the thing that a lot of you have
realized is that the Dragons themselves
look more like wyverns like the idea
that they started out as wyverns and
through selective breeding a lot of
animal husbandry they became the much
larger creatures that you see today so
when people talk about bonding with
dragons that's a refinement of the blood
magic taught to them by the people of
ash I so you can see how selective
breeding amongst themselves as well as
in their dragons was a very big thing
for Valyrian culture which is why it's
you know not that big of a deal that Jon
Snow and Daenerys hurt together it is a
continuation of something that happened
for thousands of years with the rise of
the freehold Targaryen sweat brothers
and sisters for 300 years to keep
bloodlines pure probably the most
important thing that people have started
asking now is is how do dragons
reproduce there are only two of them
that are still alive on the TV show so
unless they reproduce somehow that's it
but sort of thematically and the idea
with Daenerys in the rise again of the
Targaryen family this isn't the end of
your family as Jon Snow tells her she
might become pregnant again we'll
probably have some dragon eggs again on
the TV show so we learned through
maester aemon in his correspondence with
Rhaegar in the books that they believe
that dragons actually can switch sexes
meaning that ray Gaal could lay eggs
with Drogo eventually they in fact they
don't really refer to the Dragons
through gender Daenerys just calls them
her children but again it's just sort of
that I winked from behind the camera
like ah you know the Valyrian prophecies
are gender-neutral it could be the
princess who was promised the prince who
is promised will bring the dawn I'm
afraid I'm not a prince your grace
forgive me but your translation is not
quite accurate
that's noun has no gender in high
Valyrian so the proper translation for
that prophecy would be the prince or
princess who was promised will bring the
dawn just in that same vein the Dragons
can be both male and female but just
because Targaryens use a lot of blood
magic to tame dragon
and a lot of animal husbandry to make
them grow larger and more powerful you
still actually have to tame them when
they're born it's just like taming a new
horse you have to win them over but a
lot of you've also probably heard the
story about sheep stealer and nettles so
also sort of in the expanded material
there's a story about a dragon seed
someone who has Targaryen blood named
nettles who won over a dragon named
sheep stealer by giving it sheep every
day for about a month so eventually the
dragon just sort of cozied up to her so
the example of the TV show is that just
because the Dragons trust Jon Snow
doesn't mean that he'll just be able to
hop on one and take off and fly around
like he'll have to actually win them
over a little bit but because of the way
the show treats time like it'll jump
forward a week between scenes in a
single episode that stuff will probably
happen off screen so if we see Jon Snow
right a dragon you just have to assume
that he spent some time up at Winterfell
winning them over but the fall of
dragons actually begins after Aegon
conquers the Seven Kingdoms so as long
as you let dragons roam free and be
spectacular as Daenerys talks about
they'll just continue to growth but what
happens is is one of his eventual sons
becomes king called maegor the cruel he
actually does the exact same thing that
Cersei did at the end of season six
during a faith militant uprising at
another Sept he blows it up and on that
site he builds this dragon pit and they
start keeping dragons there chained up
so that was around 250 years before
events on the TV show pick up so it took
less than a couple hundred years for
dragons to go from the size of balerion
the black dread down to this little cat
sized skull you see here and that was
actually many many years before events
on the TV show so it was less than two
hundred years for that to happen but
even though all this focus has been on
the Targaryens and their dragons the
origin stories state the dragons were
found all over the earth at one point
meaning that there are clutches of
petrified dragon eggs all over the earth
but again if more dragons were to be
born that were not born of these to live
dragons it would require some crazy
blood magic in some really special
circumstances so it's not like it would
never happen again but the whole idea
here is that
nurses trying to break the wheel they're
trying to kill the night king so that
wouldn't need to happen again so if
there are new dragons on the TV show
they will probably flow from Riggle and
drogue on but let me know in the
comments what is your favorite part of
Dragon history on either the TV show or
in the books and what do you think the
future of dragons are do you actually
believe that they'll a dragon eggs and
at some point in the future maybe after
the show has ended you just have to
assume that new dragons are hatched but
if there are any other history videos
that you guys want me to do just let me
know in the comments below
there'll be new Game of Thrones in the
next couple days New York Comic Con is
this week so there'll be a bunch of
trailers for other related things but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Tommy's canal you win one of the
pre-orders for the DVDs please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there'll be a new round when I post that
new Game of Thrones video you can click
here for all my season 8 videos and you
can click here for a brand new Thor
Ragnarok footage thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight